[music]
in Ukraine fought for quite a long time
to celebrate exactly the 25th
and there are even a lot of
talks and yet this year we The
majority of the population
I know that 60% voted for
exactly what to celebrate on the 25th  this is an important
event for all people, and now this
year it is especially
an important date in Now, unfortunately, the war is going on,
each of us fighters wants to see his
family, but with such a conspiracy, it is very
difficult to understand that you are
celebrating with gunfire somewhere and not at home
a-  and
these are angels, these decorations were made by
my older daughters, they are in the first and
fourth grade, and now they are in Lviv, and the
evacuation gave us
our five children, but now we are a little bit.
in the evacuation
We miss them very, very much. My
father is now fighting, he is now
going out in Donetsk region,
yes, yes, and we are here, this is already 9. There will probably be a
military Christmas
in my life, because before that
S  the right is that my birthday is
on the eve of Christmas 22
and I usually
met him at home at school in the family
circle,
but at the beginning of the war I started going to
volunteers to the east of Ukraine to support
our volunteer battalions, then when
the armed forces appeared, the
armed forces supported how are you there
affairs
How did you note something briefly there or
or how it
[music]
I was an obedient boy
this strange feeling is unusual I can’t
compare it to anything because on the one
hand we will see and hear each other
on the other we are still
hundreds of kilometers away
No I can't compare
it to anything but still we are one big family
[music]